With all the work to do, people to
see traffic jams to get stuck in.
We all sometimes wish we could
be in two places at once.
We've already cloned
sheep, cows, even monkeys.
What if we cloned ourselves with clone,
have feelings and be self conscious?
Could you genetically modify them
to become better than yourself?
This is what if, and here's what
would happen if you cloned your body.
Cloning is reproducing a genetically
identical copy of an organism.
Scientists are doing that all the time,
but they aren't cloning humans.
They're mostly making copies of cells
or DNA fragments for research purposes.
Occasionally, they'll clone an
animal too. In the case of Dolly,
the sheep scientists took a somatic
cell from an adult sheep and inserted it
into an egg that had all of its DNA
information removed. Since then,
we've cloned dogs, cats, horses,
and just recently primates.
It looks like researchers have
figured this cloning thing out.
What if one day they decided
to start cloning humans?
It turns out some organisms are harder
to genetically duplicate than others.
Dogs are harder to clone them. Cats and
rats are even harder to clean than dogs.
Humans are also among the
toughest tough but possible.
What if you were the first one
ever to make a clone of yourself?
Would it be an exact copy of you?
I hate to break it to you,
but not only would your clone
have a different personality,
but they'd also look different.
Think about it this way,
just how identical are identical twins.
You may not notice at first glance,
but when you look closer,
one of them has a birthmark on their cheek
and the other one is a little toddler.
While you won't notice much of
a difference in a sheep clone,
once you look to your fresh from the lab,
you, you'd see that it's, well not you.
You're more than just a product of your
genetic code, your character behavior,
even your appearance depend on the
environment in which you were raised.
You can make a copy of your genes,
but copying your memories and
experiences is impossible. Oh,
and you realize that your clone
wouldn't be your grown up self, right?
You'd have to raise that clone baby before
they got to your age, if they ever do,
because clones are
typically very unhealthy.
Most likely they'd have a defective heart,
liver and brain,
as well as a very weak immune system.
Many cloned animals had their cells age
much faster than normal. You're cones.
Body would probably get old
and deteriorate much sooner
than you. Unfortunately,
your clone would be very
sick and die early, and they
may not even look like you.
Not to mention a totally
different personality.
Human cloning is illegal
almost everywhere on earth now.
And then a group of researchers will
claim to have cloned a human successfully,
but with no scientific
information to prove their claims.
Human cloning remains in the
realm of science fiction.
So if you're ever on a trip abroad
and meet someone who looks like you,
don't panic. The chances that
you were cloned or close to zero,
have you seen your lookalike?
What if everyone in
the world had a double? Well,
that's a story for another. What if.